welcome everyone so this is a very
special and rather unusual event
space time has always been about digging
towards the deepest layers of reality
for nearly 100 years it's felt like
we've been hovering just above
the bottom layer and so my friend and
colleague brian keating and i decided
that the fun thing to do would be to
bring together today's
frontline researchers uh in physics
experimental
and theoretical for a real conversation
so
brian is a distinguished professor at
the university of california san diego
director of the simon's observatory
uh and host of the into impossible
podcast
where you will find the craziest line of
the most incredible guest
so please check that out he's also the
author of the book losing the nobel
prize so if you want to know more about
brian and his amazing work trying to
understand the origins of the universe
that's where to look so brian thanks for
joining us
yeah thanks matt and thanks to the whole
pbs space time studios family out there
in cyberspace
uh this has been a dream for me to talk
not only with uh with matt and his team
but also with my good buddies uh today
we have stefan alexander who i've known
for
i'm embarrassed to say what fraction of
the universe we've known each other for
uh max tag mark i've known him uh almost
as long
and james beach i'm a huge fan of fellow
experimentalists looking to solve some
of
the world's greatest problems in the
world of physics and today
is uh quite fitting it's two occasions
are marked today well one
specifically uh today is karl popper's
uh would have been
karl popper's 118th birthday and uh
some say he doesn't look a day over 70
but but carl
of course is cast a large shadow over
all of what we try to do as scientists
and the question is is it still relevant
this conjecture to pursue these fanciful
ideas about theories of everything and
whether they exist
so part of the motivation is to address
that very question
and the other part is that to rekindle
the series of great debates
that took place in the 1920s actually in
april 1920 the first so-called great
debate
the curtis shapley debate which is
concern which concern what is the nature
of the universe on its largest scales
and so today we now know that the
universe's largest scale properties
are determined in part by how it
functions at the micro level
namely the laws of physics and so these
uh
these physicists who are so
distinguished joining us today
are going to hopefully shed some light
into the nature and the inner workings
of the universe
and be a really good starting point
perhaps to kick off
many more great discussions uh this year
in the centennial year
of the great debates
awesome thank you brian um so i'm gonna
bring up our guests because they have
the real content here uh uh quick
introductions
so we have james beacham who's a
particle physicist with
um the atlas experiment at the large
hadron collider at cern
and he's also at duke university and
james
is really the experimentalist in the
room and so he's going to be the one who
keeps us in check
we have stefan alexander a cosmologist
and theoretical physicist
with really a hugely broad range of
interests including
string theory and loop quantum gravity
in principle we could do this
entire conversation just with stefan
he's worked in
everything uh he's also a brilliant
saxophonist and
author of the book the jazz of physics
and of course we have
max tegmark a theoretical physicist
with an extremely broad background also
so he's worked in fields from cosmology
to the foundations of quantum mechanics
and now
actually working deep in the field of
deep learning
and he's the author of multiple books
including our mathematical universe
and the recent book life 3.0
so uh hi everyone
thanks for joining us hello it's a
pleasure to be here
thanks for having me good to see you all
in your
far-flung isolations across the globe
um so we have a lot that we need to talk
about today you know
uh we're not going to necessarily solve
the theory of everything or even fully
solve what the problem is in our search
for
a theory of everything um but i feel
like we might
be able to make a little scratch today
before we
actually get deep into that i thought it
might be a great idea
for us to set the stage uh
really talk about what we mean by a
theory of everything and the related
terms
um and i felt that the most unbiased
person to do that
is probably you james as an
experimentalist
i'm happy to to do so um and in fact
just let me just
say that i think you know ryan and matt
for putting this
fantastic discussion together because it
couldn't be more timely
and the reason you know if you ask the
question what is the theory of
everything why are we here to even talk
about this
um it's it's a really good question
because
down deep inside the answer to that
question is
related to the fact that physicists for
all of us you know we seem sometimes
kind of stuffy and nerdy and very kind
of analytical
deep down inside we're very very very
very frustrated for the following reason
um
we have two completely fantastic
wonderful theories
uh models of the way that the universe
works
in in very fundamental ways so as you
know physics is the study of
uh the fundamental laws of the universe
the way everything works at its most
elementary possible scale and we have
this one theory
that is called quantum field theory
based upon quantum mechanics and special
relativity
that so accurately describes everything
that goes on at the smallest possible
scales the particle
the level of individual uncuttable
particles
it's so fantastically good that it just
like it's wonderful it makes sure
it makes your kind of brain explode how
good it is at modeling and
predicting things that go on at the
smallest possible scales and
it's so it's it's basically passed all
of our tests this particular thing that
we call the standard model of
particle physics it's passed all of our
experimental tests so far
and it's the best description that we
have of reality at its smallest possible
scales again in terms of particles
simultaneously we have a completely
wonderful theory of something called uh
that's called general relativity which
is the fantastic description
of the way things interact at the
largest possible scales the scales of
galaxies and super clusters of galaxies
and all and the largest things in the
universe
and that's a fantastic theory of course
developed by einstein and you know the
mathematical properties developed by
some other people at the same time
you know over 100 years ago and that's
by itself
a wonderful fantastic again it's just
like chef's kiss wonderful in how good
it is at making predictions
for example as you know one of the
predictions of this theory from a
hundred years ago
was this notion of gravitational waves
and these were only uh
verified experimentally just a few years
ago so it keeps winning
over and over again in terms of these
how good it is as a theory
so you take these two things this realm
of the largest possible stuff
in the gen and governed by general
relativity and you take the realm of the
smallest possible stuff the quarks and
gluons and
electrons and things that make up you
and everything around you and you think
ah
there must be some way that these talk
to each other there must be
some way that they fit together to make
a sort of
theory of everything and when you do
that naively
remember these are two fantastically
wonderful pillars that by themselves are
just
phenomenally good when you try to marry
them together naively
everything breaks you get crazy answers
that indicate that something has gone
horribly wrong you know things like
infinite energies
or probabilities greater than one these
kinds of things indicate that there's
something wrong with your theories
so that leads us to a state that the
field has
more or less been in for you know i
guess 80 years or something where
we have these two pillars which are
wonderful and we and
you know physicists are again are humans
and so we start thinking to ourselves
there must be some way that they fit
together
to give a broader description and a more
general a more you know
a more fundamental description of
everything by putting these two things
together
and so far we have not found uh the
answer to that
and so i mean you know that's sort of
just broad strokes about what we talk
about what we mean when we talk about a
theory of everything
i can go into you know we can go into
some more details about what that means
you know the nation the notion of the
forces of nature
uh kind of unifying together and then
you know the the three forces of the
standard model going together and
unifying with gravity
um but that's more or less what uh you
know that's that's more or less
to set the stage as to what it is when
we talk about a theory of everything
fantastic james uh that i think covers
it okay so we're done here
well not quite
so you know we have a lot to get into
but what i would really
love is for perhaps the three of you to
to
talk about what you think is the state
of the field just in a few minutes
like your you know your first impulse
when we talk about
you know where are we in this great
search and and possibly you know your
instinct for a future direction
i should also add here uh that we
we're expecting lisa randall to be
joining us
uh today but she has professorial duties
um
she has some teaching duties that uh
have got in the way
uh and this is really the the most
uh truest insight that any of you will
get into our lives uh
our teaching tends to take us away uh at
a moment's notice but she will be
joining us next week and we'll have more
details of that soon
okay um so maybe stefan would you like
to
take it from here yeah thanks matt um
it's a real
honor and pleasure to be joining i'm
actually a big fan of maths actually you
know you happen to think
and get to see that you and brian are
doing this um
i'd like to say brian's will you know
they're gonna be the next carl sagan
you know of our days um got the skills
going on there
um so yeah i mean where i can come in
is that i work in you know
at the interface of particle physics
theory and cosmology theory
um so going back to what james wonderful
presentation and overview
of kind of particle physics b in the
realm where we are probing the smallest
distance scale in nature at the smallest
distance scale
and cosmology is the science where we're
looking at things also the largest
difference
and the oldest times the um
time scales um quantum gravity
is a realm where we're trying to answer
both of those questions you know
um mysteries um observational mysteries
actually
observational anomalies in the realm
where particle physics overlap
with cosmology so that's some of us
refer to ourselves as particle
cosmologists
and i being a theorist i obviously has i
have to engage with quantum gravity
and my take on this is that i've always
come come to that with
um from the perspective of um
i would say inspired by my my big
inspiration is richard feynman which is
you have your pro your puzzles in
physics and then you
you you you go to whatever tool kit you
have available
and you're kind of agnostic about that
toolkit so i'm not married to any
approach to quantum gravity
or any approach i mean when it comes to
theories uh have yet been tested
experimentally
so as a result you know i've worked on
both published both in loop quantum
gravity
applied to problems in cosmology and
particle physics
as well as string theory applied to
cosmology
so let me just kind of lay out kind of
you know my perspective
on both approaches from a more general
tape
and it actually starts back with albert
einstein i think the big contribution
einstein made was in terms of
modern physics and of course this was
applied to general relativity and
special relativity
is a principle of invariance the idea
that
there are underlying symmetries in this
case symmetries that leave the speed of
light
um the same value for all different
observers in that case
for special relativity or symmetries
under any
change of coordinate systems the
principle of general covariance which is
not
nothing more than an invariance
principle
um and this principle um kind of lived
with us
under the name the guise of symmetry um
so that has really dictated a lot of of
um
you know fundamental physics leading to
um string theory itself so string theory
really is driven by this the idea that
as we go to the shortest shortest
distance scale we are to expect to see
more and more symmetries unveiling
itself and so that's one that's kind of
one philosophy
or take hypothesis that has driven
research in string theory or things you
may hear about super symmetry for
example
um which is a kind of part of string
theory as well
and it's but there's another thing in
string theory that i think we should um
i think that's interesting which is that
in string theory you don't start off
with a theory of gravity
right string theory is an approach to
try to combine ideas of gravity
with with quantum mechanics together as
um as james
pointed out and the idea in string
theory in a nutshell is that you start
with a
instead of a point particle you start
with a string
and the string has certain symmetries
associated how it moves about
and then you quantize that theory and
when you do that and you try to keep
quantum mechanics consistent the
assumptions you made about quantum
mechanics
pops out of the equations out of that
equation
gravity quote unquote albeit and 10
dimensions and supersymmetric
pops out general relativity in that guys
pops out
now it's the wrong theory of gravity i
must add right
but in that sense string theory you know
starts with quantum mechanics and an
assumption about
certain symmetries and gravity emerges
and i'm going to use that word
um as us you know from max and maybe
true on a little bit
but loop quantum gravity is another
approach to quantum gravity that tries
to again
similarly combine quantum mechanics with
relativity
but it does it in a different way like
what luke
quantum gravity does it says let's take
general relativity as it is let's take
einstein's theory of general relativity
you know good old as that works it works
it explains gravitate it predicts
gravitational waves and black holes
all these zany things that have been
observed experimentally
it takes general relativity and it says
let's quantize that let's apply the laws
of quantum mechanics to general
relativity
and there is a caveat i'm going to say
if you do this you're going to run into
a problem
but anyway they can succeed in kind of
doing this and then you get this thing
we call loop quantum gravity
um and that's both theories they're both
incomplete they're both limited
they're both they both have their own
strengths and weaknesses string theory
is a lot more developed there are many
more people that
have worked on string theory you can do
a lot of
cool model building with with string
theory i've certainly done that
um lukewarm gravity there's some
interesting questions connected to
particle physics that
i've worked on but i'm gonna now say the
following thing
i am left puzzled because
it seems that when you do both string
theory and loop quantum gravity and you
try to apply quantization
there are some unquestioned things that
we assume about quantum mechanics
that i think that are foundational that
i think
physicists no matter how bright we think
we are and how it's smart and elegant
and all that stuff
i think went unquestioned and some of
the problems that we see
lurking in both string theory why
they're all these 10 dimensions and why
we only live in four
what happened to supersymmetry all these
things marginalized stable all these
fancy things
and the quantum gravity time disappears
um
that uh very unsettling to me personally
and as a result i've taken a step back
and just tried doing other things while
i wait for
max tag mark to solve the problem so i'm
just gonna
that's a beautiful segway and improv
master stefan alexander has always been
and now we turn to uh one of my favorite
most mercurial personalities in the
world uh who when i met him as a second
or third year grad student
helped take me under his wing even
though he's a theorist and uh and i was
an experimentalist still am
and i said that must be why you're
called max million and he said no
i'm just max for now someday i'll be a
millionaire and max with all your great
contributions to humanity
uh in your writings in your personal
humanity
you're you're an mit mensch as we say uh
like you first introduce yourself
uh for those uh 10 people who may be
watching out of the tens of thousands
who may not know you and then can you
give us your take on where things stand
what guides you and why why you think
this is such a critical juncture
for physicists such as us to be
discussing such esoteric topics
yeah so uh i'm feeling a lot of pressure
piled on me already here
especially by you stephanie counting on
me answering all the questions
uh but i'm i'm i'm honored to be with
you guys here
my favorite thing to do in a pandemic in
a very polarized world is to talk with
people like you who remind me about the
really important stuff you know here we
are
almost 80 billion of us on this little
spinning ball in space
who actually amazingly after 13.8
billion years of cosmic history
managed to start figuring a bunch of
stuff out and
i think this is a great reminder for us
all to not lose sight of the really big
important picture so uh let me give you
my take on on theories of everything for
the brief
history of what i think we've
accomplished and where i think we've
failed and let me also um
take this opportunity to uh attack
physicist arrogance a little bit
so
when we say theories of everything
we have often tend to be very
circumscribed and said well
physics is just supposed to do this and
that's what we mean by everything and
all the other things that maybe
by biologists and others do that doesn't
count this
everything which i find a little bit
arrogant uh but so and what happened was
of course
in already in ancient greek times and
antiquity people were able to figure out
some aspects of how
stuff worked they realized that when you
throw something
or a catapult hurls a rock you can
figure out the motions archimedes did a
lot of stuff on that
but other things they just sort of gave
up on like why doesn't the moon fall
down well you know
presumably that's just off limits for
physics heavenly objects
obey different rules they're perfect
heaven stuff just shut up don't ask
those questions
almost a sort of censorship attitude you
know shut up
you're asking too much uh gradually
physicists have challenged this and
started asking those questions anyway
isaac newton came along and said hey
wait a minute it's a perfectly legit
question to ask why the moon doesn't
fall down
what if in fact the laws of gravity that
work on earth also apply up in the sky
and boom they did work but even at that
time
it was still incredibly limited what we
meant by
the scope of physics and everything that
they were after
it was basic if you took newton and he
and you had him throw a hazelnut than a
grape
right and he could predict very
accurately the shape in which they would
fly a parabola
y equals x squared and how long it would
take for him to land but he had no clue
why the grape was green and the hazelnut
was brown or why the grape was soft and
squishy and the hazelnut was hard right
that was beyond physics then
came maxwell's equations and gave us all
sorts of math for colors and light
and then came quantum mechanics that we
just heard about here
from james and stefan that explained
actually why the hazelnut is hard and
the grape is soft
and we've now gone from after the
standard model of particle physics and
so much else
from the situation where physics could
apply
be applied to almost none of the aspects
of the world around us except motion
to one where it can actually apply to
most
of the aspects of the world around us
and it's a perfect time in our
conversation to ask well
when we talk about theories of
everything what are we leaving out this
time
from everything and i actually think we
should be even more ambitious than just
talking about
quantum gravity and i didn't mean to use
the word just
there to in any way imply the quantum
gravity is easy but that's not
all i think we should aspire to do
i was very inspired like you stephon by
by richard feynman also very much by his
advisor
john archibald wheeler who who once told
me that he went through three phases in
life
first it's all particles
so that's not your quantum mechanics
then it's all fields
and not the general relativity and this
third phase
it's all information and
i would argue that the important aspects
of the world around us that we
understand the most poorly now are
actually related to information
more specifically they are intelligence
and consciousness which i happen to
think are
also things that we should look at as
scientists and
confess that we have failed to
uh to really understand well i i'm
i happen some people think well we're
screwed just like some people thought
you could never understand why the moon
doesn't fall down
they think maybe we'll never understand
intelligence or consciousness because
somehow it involves a soul
or some life essence that's just sort of
beyond physics
i have um i'm more optimistic my guess
is that the information that is all just
information
and that both intelligence and
consciousness are simply in
certain kinds of information processing
that we as physicists have so far failed
to find the equations that describe we
know that some
information can be processed very
intelligently without there seemingly
being any consciousness there because
most of the information processing in
our brain we're not aware of how
we're not conscious of and maybe you can
also have
some conscious experiences that are
without there being very much
intelligence there
i promise to not say anything about
politics so i won't
and but so to summarize i i think
to me when we talk about theories of
everything we should aspire to also
understand
more about what intelligence and
consciousness is and and not just
because it's important
and interesting but because actually i
would argue that many of the biggest
failures we have in
the finding a theory of everything in
the traditional sense of quantum gravity
have to do with us trying to sweep under
the carpet
the question of what is an observer
really
no here we have quantum mechanics and
general relativity they have basically
exact opposite
notions of an observer in general
relativity right an observer is this
infinitesimally light
infinitesimally small particle that has
no effect on anything else
and in quantum mechanics the observer
actually affects that which
is observed so if you're not going to
define what an observer is or
talk about that or try to make a
physical model of it you know
no wonder we're stuck unifying these
these theories
have officially given us permission to
pursue any question
at all as physicists future episodes of
space time are going to get very weird
good more you're gonna get more weird uh
so you know so james we may be able to
ask any question as physicists but that
doesn't mean we can answer any question
um uh i feel like you might have a
a more measured uh approach to
uh thinking about the state of the field
um uh
constrained as you are as an
experimentalist uh what are your
thoughts
well first i wanted to just kind of jump
upon one thing that uh
max said there which you know and also
to answer your question because when i
when i you know as any especially
experimentalist i'm
i sort of two people at the same time i
have to be the uh
extremely excitable curious you know kid
who likes to think about these things
from a very basic philosophical
perspective you know
it's like what's outside the universe
you know how small can i cut anything
you know these kind of
are there more than one universe these
kinds of things but i also at the same
time i have to
at the end of the day say is this
something that i can possibly ever test
and i don't necessarily mean within my
lifetime because i don't like to think
about just
you know science is being valid only
when discoveries are made within my
lifetime
i think about in in general is there
some idea you know if someone comes up
with an idea
and it's not possible for me to even
formulate you know a
a coherent description of how i would
ever possibly test this idea
then i am rightfully skeptical of this
idea you know if you know what i mean
and so you know
one of the things that i always think
about when you know for example max set
the stage really nicely for discussions
like this because
i completely agree from one perspective
that the notion of consciousness and
intelligence are very
interesting things and in fact they have
to be addressed scientifically
but i also think that those two concepts
honestly to me they don't have i've
never seen a complete
you know uh coherent consistent
description uh definition of what those
are
that i could ever really actually test
and like in a in a scientific way
in a physics experiment in a way and so
otherwise
i mean what i see is something like you
know and i think the concept of
emergence is fascinating and i think it
definitely needs to be looked into more
closely but
the for me if i want to just be totally
materialistic and everything i say look
consciousness is really just some
complex pattern of neuronal impulses
which is based upon electromagnetism in
my brain
and so in principle i could be able to
model this right and
if i have sufficiently advanced
computers i could be able to model this
at some point
and then i you know at some point i
should be able to you know create uh
some kind of comp
program that could replicate this etc
you know etc
so this is the you know this is the way
that i have to think about these kinds
of ideas
and so when i come to ideas that are
theories of everything
um i also have to be simultaneously
excited and uh you know looking for the
next you know the the next uh
big idea the next crazy idea that you
know the wild idea that might
unify quantum mechanics and gravity or
the next wild eye that that might
actually take a step back and supplant
those two pillars with a more coherent
framework which is
what a lot of the things that max and
lisa and stefan have worked on in the
past
but at the end of the day i you know i
i'm not from missouri but i'm the
missouri man
show me right show me i want to know you
know what the what the
you know i want to be able to test this
thing in a way and so to my mind the
the from as an experimentalist
especially working at cern right
is that we are currently at a really
interesting juncture in
experimental physics especially
experimental particle physics
is that we have this fantastic machine
the largest experiment ever
ever built a 27 kilometer circular
tunnel on the border of france and
switzerland 100 meters underground the
large hadron collider
and we accelerate protons to 13 trillion
electron volts
and we smash them together you know 40
million times a second recreate the
conditions of the
universe after the big bang etc and we
have and this is this huge jump into the
unknown and
you know this gigantic energy reach you
know as you know from uh e equals m c
squared if nature has a particle with
the mass m that's all the way up here
and we as a species have only ever built
a collider to with it goes up to e here
we'll never be able to produce it and
measure its properties so the large
hadron colliders with this huge jump
into the unknown
with all of these things that stefan was
talking about sort of behind the scenes
things we were looking for
you know things like uh super symmetry
particles um
you know speaking of uh lisa you know
randall some sunderm gravitons large
extra dimensions
any of these would be fantastic answers
to some of the biggest questions that
we've been facing in physics for a very
long time
and now flash forward to 2020 and we
have found precisely one new particle
and that's really really interesting
because it's a very very wild and
fascinating and wonderful particle of
the higgs boson which is
completely unlike any other thing we've
ever discovered in
physics ever so but it's also weird
because it's the only thing we've found
so far
again we're going to probably take we're
going to take something like 50 to you
know 50 times the data that we have
right now with the
with the with the large hadron collider
in the future but as it stands now
it's strange that we have this very
lonely higgs boson sitting right here
so that makes us start to think very
critically about sort of the
the the sort of uh um the the
you know these the kind of motivations
for the experiments and it also leads us
to this very very interesting juncture
because
with the higgs boson discovery we kind
of were complete that's like
more or less we're now out we are out of
concrete you know sort of no
lose predictions as to what to find in
particle physics experiments
and that's bizarre in a way it's a very
weird place to be and
you know intellectually because the
entire history of the 20th century
for particle physics was you know there
was some kind of weird observation
somebody makes a theoretical prediction
and it's like that can't possibly be
true
pow it was true and then somebody else
made an amazing thing and this this kept
happening over and over and over and the
last thing to be predicted
definitively was a higgs boson and now
it's there but we also have all these
gigantic open questions
including how do quantum mechanics and
gravity work together
but we don't have any big kind of like
magic bullet directions as to how we
should answer this so
that to me is the kind of the crux of
why this is such a
such a you know a unique weird place to
be but also exciting
because it gives us a chance to you know
get back to our roots as kind of just
experimentalists and let's just explore
let's explore
because exploration has always paid off
in the past and so this is why people
talk about you know next generation of
colliders and the next the next
generation of colliders going to the
high
as high energies as we possibly can the
you know we can talk about this
if you want but of course the the
ultimate possible energy you know if you
just give me a couple of seconds to
finish
the the way to you know to my mind as an
experimentalist the way to really answer
this question
i mean i'm totally okay i completely
want all predictions from string theory
you know so i want string theorists and
you know to come up with some kind of
oblique way we might be able to see like
a hot spot or
you know uh some poles in the cmb or i
want them to say you know we can
actually see this
you know string theory evidence of
string theory showing up an xyz
experiment to lower energies
i want these things to happen but at the
same time
we know that there's one energy that we
have to achieve
that would basically tell us lots and
lots about the way quantum mechanics and
gravity work together and this is the
plunk energy and as
all of you guys know if you take the
basic you know if you take the basic uh
constants of nature uh you know plunks
constant gravitational constant speed of
light things like this
these numbers that just sort of they're
they're there these these
these uh constants have these values and
there's no particular reason for why
these values are the way they are
but if you arrange them in certain ways
they're very fundamental and so if you
arrange them in certain ways to get
dimensions and of
energy and length and time they give you
these things called plunk scales
and that suggests that that's the place
where quantum mechanics and gravity they
have to have something to do with each
other
there has to be some connection there
and maybe it happens much much before
this energy but that's the place where
it has to happen
and so this is the so-called plonk
energy the problem with that of course
is that
with current uh with current technology
with current collider
you know experimental technology it's
not clear that our civilization will
ever be able to build a large enough
collider to reach the planck energy
and even if you did you might just
create a gigantic black hole so
it's not entirely clear how we get there
and how we would do that within a
reasonable amount of time
but that's the part that sort of to me
is the kind of if you want to get down
to it experimentally it's like if we
were able to reach the planck scale in a
collider
that would tell us a lot and that would
be a fantastic way to
you know really dive into what are the
experimental you know evidence that we'd
have for
any kind of theory of everything yeah we
didn't set up the uh
the super chat but uh had we done so
we could take uh take donations uh just
kidding we're not gonna take donations
for that giant collider
uh but that does bring us to this
question as i mentioned earlier at the
beginning today would have been karl
popper's 118th birthday
uh he looks pretty good for his age and
i want to know
you know kind of are we being kind of
overwhelmed by the influence of popper
in that we seek this notion of
falsifiability as the apiotheus
of um of what a theory should be
testable and how it should be uh proven
or disproven if you will
uh when we lack sort of the
comprehensive ability in physics to
really prove things
and the question is is that the best we
can do can we only live up to poppers
demarcation hypothesis and
falsifiability
in terms of validating in an era when we
might not ever be able to build that
that you know solar system-sized
accelerator or even an accelerator
bigger than the
you know than the current future
circular collider so maybe we'll start
with james uh
go back to you are aren't we not a
approaching the limits of experimental
particle physics and b
are we missing things that could be
hiding in plain sight i mean there's a
huge number of questions that remain
such as you know why are there 16 or so
17
fundamental particles where does that
number come from why are there three
generations
what's the cosmological constant telling
us should those not be used
as the as the occam's razor you know to
to discriminate theories uh from you
know pure
wild speculation right and i
saw that max had his hand up so i think
he really wanted to say something
what i was going to say max do you want
to say i'm happy to answer the question
why don't you go first
max and then and then just a relatively
quick uh
comment to the interesting stuff you
said there james about
consciousness and show me show me
i'm a big proper fan so happy birthday
carl
first of all and and second i think well
the reason that artificial intelligence
has gone from science fiction to being
actual science with real conferences and
real money and real companies and so on
is exactly because
this field has succeeded in showing you
stuff feinman who stefan brought up
right
used to say you only understand things
once you can build them
so if someone thinks they understand how
to make a machine that's intelligent
enough to
kick your butt in chess or go you should
ask them to build it
and now people have done that so that
that's progress
and i also just wanted to add that um
i think even though it's it's i think we
need
to think about that even for addressing
some of the quantum gravity questions
because
uh you you stated and i completely agree
with you james it is depressing how hard
it
is to even envision a collider that
could detect detect an individual
graviton or give the kind of
experimental hints you might want for
quantum gravity but i think in the
meantime
we can actually make a lot of progress
you doing theoretical work
uh for example if you have a theory of
quantum gravity right
then not only should you be able to have
a thing an object
in two places at once like in
superposition like in ordinary quantum
mechanics
but you should have be able to have the
shape of space being in two different
ways at once what does that even mean
the superposition of two distances
or or two different time intervals and
and i think to answer this if you want
to be really preparing and be like show
me what you need to do is say well
okay here is stefan's theory here's
james's theory
here's so-and-so's theory let's work out
what observers will actually observe
if it were stefan's way if it were
james way et cetera and to do that you
have to
say okay here's a bunch of particles
moving around processing information
how do they experience this does it feel
this way or that way now you're facing
this question of
mental processes right and i i think
honestly in physics
this has been just as hard often as
finding the math right like
look at einstein for instance his real
genius wasn't figuring out the math of
special relativity which is
relatively simple right and minkowski
had written down a lot of it in lorentz
before him
but rather it was exactly this stuff of
figuring out
how an observer would actually
experience things realizing that hey
wait a minute
what this complicated equation here
means is that it's gonna
that the object that the moving this
observer here is gonna feel that
time has slowed down people are like
whoa
that's so weird right and i think uh
to predict what it is actually going to
what
what observers will observe and
experience
in various quantum gravity theory is
going to be even harder and i don't
think we can do it if we just try to
sweep the whole question of what an
observer is under the carpet
just to jump off of that and also go
back to your question brian
um i you know i didn't want to just to
be clear i didn't want to at all
you know try to denigrate any kind of
theoretical work it absolutely has to be
done i hope that i made it clear that i
want all of these theories i want all
the new ideas i want all the craziest
ideas
and i think that that's really really
important because that's why for example
i
you know i do take seriously when
somebody like you know uh
for just for example eric ferlindy comes
up with an idea that maybe dark matter
and gravity are in fact
emergent properties of sort of the
quantum cubit structure
informational structure of space-time
right i mean even as an experimentalist
you know with
six years of grads grad school and
quantified i hear that i'm like
what does that even mean right and so i
want to go deep into it
and understand what that means because
it in fact could lead to
a much more fundamental understanding of
what we understand or
what we what we know about the universe
from a very different perspective which
is i think a little bit what you're
alluding to max right it's like
when when when you know when you try to
recenter what it means to be an observer
and try to reframe that and recognize
that there's a totally different
description of that
that's not just a slight tweak it's not
an improvement it's a complete
shift you know to forget about popper
let's talk about cune right it's an
actual paradigm shift with respect to
the way
you you you view the entirety of this
field those are the things that i think
are really fascinating to think about
but at the same time i completely agree
brian that
experimentally you know and to on to
answer your question experimentally what
we have to do at
all of these things and i i am very much
you know i
i can't underscore enough how what a
what a fantastic time it is to be
a you know a physicist right now an
experimentalist because
we have all these amazing open questions
and there's no guarantees anymore and so
we really you know we're required
to think in big ways both theoretically
and also experimentally
and so and experimentally thinking big
does not just mean
the sort of obvious things like a future
circular collider at cern of course you
have to have bigger colliders there's no
question there because otherwise you'll
never be able to know what's there
at the same time you absolutely can you
need to do these other experiments too
like really nailing down the
cosmological constant really doing
precision measurements
in all different types of lower energy
machines right because the standard
model is this
wonderful sort of like brick that has
all these wonderful you know predictions
that have come out of it and it makes
all these really precise predictions
and basically all of them have have been
you know have been
verified except there's a lot that are
that we never even bothered to yet
because
you know it's like we just assume
they're right because it's been right
about everything else
but that's really where the new portal
to some brand new discovery could be we
have to really hammer at the edges of
this thing too
so i think all these things can happen
simultaneously i don't think we should
limit ourselves
as as a species to only doing it's like
well i'm going to build a 100 kilometer
uh you know 100 kilometer 100 tv
collider and that's the only thing i do
absolutely not you got to do everything
you got to do everything why stop there
so i want to turn this to my friend
stefan uh stefan you know
as i said it's always held up that you
know this this falsifiability
is sort of as sacrosanct as girdle's
incompleteness theorem is in mathematics
and i've had this discussion with
with you with janna levin uh even with
eric weinstein and others you know
do are we holding up popper to this
unrealistic
you know standard golden standard i know
you know max has a has a little doll
like i have of carl sagan here
he has a little thumb doll of of carl
popper that he he puts on and still
plays a heck of a violin
uh but i want to know stefan are we
really you know kind of worshiping at
the altar
of of popper and yes to give the dead
man is due
today's his birthday but let's let's
let's as
uh address this question is there too
much emphasis placed on
falsifiability and maybe as some say in
the comments and elsewhere
we should be looking beyond popper to a
post-paparian
uh of what constitutes science
can it only be falsifiable science that
quote-unquote
counts
that's a very tough question so i'll
just give my spin on it no pun intended
um
i think i do think that that that
criterion
um for the nature of the issues that we
deal with and we can even
um see some of this immediately just by
looking at some of the problems
faced by quantum mechanics itself that
that standard
is um too much and i definitely resonate
i
i never used to actually i used to think
max was a madman
not mad max but uh we we go a little way
back too you know
but i've grown
i'm i'm not sure max has his own
opinions about me
but um i would say that i've i've grown
um sympathetic to max's point of view
um and the real challenge will be
actually to james and his colleagues of
how
how then do you if you if you relax the
constraints of pop you know
of of popper that you know science
should be falsified what you define as
science the scientific evidence should
be falsifiable
um so let me give an example of this
actually and i want to throw this out
first maybe to
to um to my colleagues here to discuss a
little bit
um the measurement problem in quantum
mechanics and the young's double
experiment to me was a quintessential
example of this
and let me just say a few things about
that very quickly the experiment
right you can do it you don't need to go
to high energies uh i did it in my
intro physics class um with the help of
our lab assistant our lab tech
last semester at brown and um the basic
experiment
is you um well there's a modern version
of the experiment
you shoot you have like you know um a
wall
right with two little holes um so that
particles can go through the holes and
then you have a screen
that collects the particles at the end
and you shoot one electron at a time
you know um and the electro you can do
this with light as well with photons
and then what you see is that the
electrons deposit themselves as
particles on the wall
and so you're like oh that's good
because the electrons you know will go
through one hole
go through another hole and it will be
blocked by you know
the rest of the wall you know the um and
then you'd see
all these electrons build up and what
you end up seeing is a wave like
patterns all the electrons will deposit
themselves
and have this wave-like pattern so then
you'll say well that's weird because
that's what waves do not particles
and the electrons come out as particles
so this is uh
well you're so okay let's go to look to
see where the electron goes
and when the observer goes to look to
see where the electron goes
the wave-like pattern just disappears
completely so this is weird and then you
say okay you go back to quantum theory
and you say quantum theory tell me um
to explain and predict um the role of
the observer in doing this and
up to today we don't have a post
parparian
explanation to this now i do know that
max's with my friend anthony agreer has
written
some papers about having certain
interpretations of this
where you get multiple you have to in
you know expand quantum mechanics
they're having
multiple copies of the same of of max
tech marks
right um the so-called max i think your
advisor was
john ultra ball wheel as well right and
back when i was a postdoc in princeton
and right and i think that so anyway let
me just throw this out to say that
for me i'm already convinced that even
like you know the double suit experiment
other other things that quantum
mechanics in ordinary quantum mechanics
presents itself um let me also say that
those things are also magical features
of quantum mechanics that we use
to try to build quantum computers today
but
they're very weird and it seems that
like to really
try to understand those things you kind
of have to
relax the rules about in this case the
role of the observers or what the sets
of assumptions that we're making
i don't claim that i have anything more
to say about
as a theorist about how to address that
but i kind of want to throw it out there
to say that i think we've already
entered into that realm um
so let me just stop right there with
that
sure i am a great fan of popper but hey
you know
um we can always build up this upgrade
things a little bit
you know if you just take the
simple-minded point of view that every
theory is either true or false
and and um the whole purpose so the
definition of a theory is
so they can be falsified like popper
said then in that case the theory that
newton of newtonian physics
is really just as bad as the theory that
earth is flat they're both false they've
been
falsified by data right but that doesn't
seem quite
fair to say so what in what sense is is
newton's gravity better
i so i told you i mentioned before
john wheeler right in his his final uh
phase of life that it's all information
i think actually information
information theory is another
alternative way gives you an alternative
way to define what you mean by
science very loosely speaking
i would say a theory is something is
good science if you get more out of it
than what you put into it for example i
found this
book once in the university of
pennsylvania library
is about this thick and it had over a
hundred thousand numbers in it
they were measured wavelengths of light
coming out of all sorts of different
atoms all right
and it just hit me that all those
numbers can now be
calculated super accurately from just
three numbers
by stefan or james using the schrodinger
equation
that's data compression if you're a
computer scientist it's even better than
g
zip minus nine it's amazing you got so
much more out of quantum mechanic
of quantum mechanics than you put in
right put in three numbers get out a
hundred thousand
um in contrast if you
try to predict the 32 fundamental
constants of the standard model
using some new model that itself has a
thousand parameters that's pretty un
unimpressive and it's what people in ai
research would just call
call overfitting so you can you can make
this into a definition of
of of scientific theories if you want
and say that the
if having the theory lets you compress
the data set
so you can describe the data set plus
the theory itself with much less
information
much fewer bits than you than earlier
hey that's progress so and in that sense
newton's gravity was enormous progress
sure it didn't describe things perfectly
it was ultimately wrong because it
didn't include relativistic effects
but you know we become sufficiently
humble in physics now anyway to
acknowledge that probably every single
single theory we teach
in our university courses anyway it's
just the approximation for
something else right quantum gravity or
whatever something else that we don't
have yet
so i actually think this information
theory way of looking at it is
more true to the spirit of what we
actually do
as scientists and it also gives a
kind of a way of thinking about
children as scientists and as in general
brains as scientists because
we have the brain exactly in order to be
able to make predictions about the
future right
where to find food where to not get
eaten by tigers and stuff like this
and one can it's it's not hard to prove
that
the key to making data compression if
you have too
little space free on your hard drive and
you want to one of these programs what
it always tries to do is
predict what the next stuff in your file
is going to be from what it's already
read
and and then it can store that with much
much less space
so if you take the if you take the just
general definition of
of science as being able to make better
predictions of the
of the future than you could before then
i think you james are happy because it's
you're making predictions
and but it's not as rigid as as popular
that you would reject things just
because you're not perfect
turn to james uh to address some
really uh fast and furious things coming
in the comments
um so we physicists are very fond of
swag and if you go to
and enter the the uh pbs spacetime
website events you'll be registered to
win swag for next time and even books by
our guest next week
but you know here's an example of swag
so this is my official simon's
observatory
cap and we put on it its coordinates so
we put on cerro toco chile 5150 meters
and this is this is 2020 edition so it's
fresh off the
printing presses uh i've often heard it
said what we really want is an equation
that uh fits on a t-shirt or perhaps
next next year 2021's
uh is that a legitimate goal or is that
just a cute trope that
allows physicists to get away with
saying funny things
stefan yeah sorry
wear my cern t-shirt that has the
standard model lagrangian on it yeah
please sorry go ahead yeah take it away
so i don't think i
i yeah this is like i have a very very
strong uh
opinion about this um i don't think that
math
will is gonna completely um capture
of the fundamental if there is a
fundamental theory it's just going to be
um just math math player has played a
role
but math um is a tool it's a language
it's been very convenient
um but um but i think we're going to
need more than just math like the same
way
we rely on intuition and then mat you
know to come up with
a theory sometimes um
[Music]
i i can tell you about an interesting
feynman story i learned from my friend
john lanier one of the
pioneers of virtual reality of how
feynman was doing physics
near the end of his life not using math
okay
um but the point is i think math will be
part of the
would be a good useful tool but this
idea of shut up and calculate and that
fun finally the final fear of everything
will be a set of equation or one
equation
i have strong feelings about that i
think that'll be part of it but
there there's going to be other tools
that we're gonna have to draw from and i
don't know what that is it might look a
little bit like
what max is pointing to we probably need
some observers floating out there what
have you
um but but i so i so in a nutshell i
don't think math is going to be the only
thing
so we find ourselves with the
experimental floor dropped from beneath
our feet and we're
trying to navigate in this realm of pure
mathematical and theoretical
you know landscape but we have this
guide
you know certainly string theory has
followed this guide of you know
following the beauty following the
symmetry and the elegance
and we've been doing it for such a long
time even paul durak said that
it's better to have beauty in one's
equations than to have them
fit experiment which i by that i think
he meant that
experiments can be wrong but if your
equation is ugly it's definitely not
right
but but but surely that's telling us
something why
is it that this mathematical elegance
leads us
so truly even if it does sometimes lead
us astray
i'm happy for anyone to address this
because i would love
to know
um oh you know a lot of the things we've
been discussing here and i think that at
the end of the day
i in fact have a slightly different
perspective on this
um than you might expect from some you
know experimentalists
i'm not strictly uh you know a popparian
or a paparite if you will
um and i'm also not you know because i
don't think that falsifiability is the
only
you know the main criterion that we need
to rely upon for any kind of theory
um and you know for you know for example
one of the one of the most interesting
things that i see in
physics right now is this concept of a
multiverse whether it comes from string
theory whether it comes from just
inflation or a big bang theory
you know this idea is fascinating as it
stands now there's basically no way that
i can coherently
you know define how to test that as an
idea right now there's some kind of
vague ideas there's some vague sort of
possible hand-waving things but it
doesn't mean that it's non-scientific
it doesn't mean that it's uh you know
it's not science because we followed
that we started with things that are
known science we followed the chain of
logic to arrive at this
very strange conclusion that there could
be you know a multiverse
amongst which we are only one it doesn't
mean that you know just because we can't
falsify it now it doesn't mean we can't
you know it doesn't mean we can't test
it now it doesn't mean we can't in the
future
right and so that's related to what you
were saying matt because you know i also
think that you know in this notion of
that you know stefan you're talking
about you know elegance of like a
mathematic you know like a
an equation that should be beautiful and
dirac saying these things i in fact i'm
much more along the lines of you know
my colleague stephen weinberg who said
simplicity is not a scientific principle
and whether or not you have a beautiful
equation whether or not you have a
simple theory it doesn't mean anything
because the universe
doesn't care whether we think that its
laws are simple or elegant or beautiful
at all
and you know and we have in fact we
might say that you know say the the
standard model of particle physics maybe
from one perspective it's kind of
beautiful
but from another perspective it's very
baroque it's like why should our
universe have as its
gauge theory su 3 cross su 2 cross u1
there's there's no reason for that it's
very complex there could be a million
other choices
why is it that our universe happened to
choose this one
instantiation of a mathematical set of
objects to make real
and then a bunch of other possibilities
i can write down are not there
so that to me is not so simple it's you
know it's not beautiful
it's just it is and so i would not even
i would not go to the
i i try not to rush to the notion of
something needs to be beautiful
for it to be you know uh true because
you know we're just humans
may have something to say on that yeah
you raise they're getting to the
really good stuff here are all the
questions that we don't know the answer
to so there is i i want to
say something brief about what you
mentioned about the multiverse and
whether it's testable or not
and i also want to tell you something
brief
about uh the business of math and it's
whether it's fundamental or not so it's
starting with the multiverse here
how can the multiverse get along with
popper you say you kind of like the
multiverse but
also like popper it seems very
untestable right talking about places
that are so far away that we could never
go there even if
we traveled at the speed of light
forever surely
that's not testable so i the way i
feel we should honor popper on his
birthday
is to just give him some credit
for for being very clear on what it was
that was supposed to be testable
he said it's a theory that's supposed to
be testable
not necessarily every single prediction
of the theory
yeah so let me give a metaphor before we
go multiversal
take a theory of general relativity
right it predicts stuff that we can
never observe namely exactly what
happens inside of a black hole
right yes you could jump into
sagittarius a star the 4 million solar
mass black hole at the middle of our
galaxy and make some observations before
you get crushed
but you can never publish your results
in science or nature or tell your
friends right
so does that mean we should
no because general relativity also made
other predictions that we can
test like the perihelion shift the
mercury the bending of starlight around
the sun
all sorts of general relativity stuff
with ligo and gravitational waves etc
so what we've done is we've tested the
theory many times
we agreed that the theory is science and
if we choose to take it seriously we
have to take seriously all the
predictions of general relativity not
just the ones we can observe
i think it's exactly the same way with
the theory of inflation
if you take seriously alan guth and
andre linde and and the others
the theory of inflation and you also
take seriously
the idea that the
that the quantum gravity has more than
one solution corresponding to some sort
of uniform space with stuff in it
then inflation tends to generically
predict that you're going to make
lots of space typically much more space
than we can observe
and kind of uniformly full of stuff
starting out in all sorts of different
ways
uh can we fly away and see the nearest
parallel universe
where max smegmark is talking with
james mitchum and schmeffon
schmalexander no of course we cannot
right
are those they're super partners are
those fortunately hundreds
of predicted a whole bunch of other
stuff that many of us including you
brian
have worked on measuring like the
curvature space that's supposed to be
omega's
total is supposed to be one and it's
1.00
etcetera to test it to better than a
percent
so it's it's stuff so this is how i
think we can reconcile
the multiverse with popper the ultimate
the ultimate reality out there may be
much bigger than we can observe
fine there's no law of nature saying we
should be able to observe everything
that exists it'd be kind of arrogant
to presume that like an ostrich saying
you know if i can't see it
it can't exist but as long as as long as
the theories that predict that stuff
also predict other things that we can
test
then those theories are scientific so
that's that's my birthday present to
popper
and maintain his relevance in the era of
the multiverse and speaking of his
birthday
you know his his original kind of target
of his ire was astrology
so i i guess what is he what would he
have been a libra i forget
i'm not good with my astrology he's
probably rolling in his grave right
do you want me to say i'm thinking about
math also or should we yeah
please max go ahead so
this is a wonderful question of course
why is it that
math has been so useful in describing
our world
because ultimate math is one of the most
successful kinds of data compression
we've come across right you can write
down an equation on a blackboard
that can dramatically simplify
your description of things why is that
did it have to be that way
already galileo was really impressed by
this right when he when he
said 400 years ago that our universe is
like a grand book written in the
language of math
and vig eugene wigner wrote this essay
in the 60s about the unreasonable
effectiveness of math and since then
you guys have as physicists have just
been piling it on now there's a standard
model of particle physics and now
einstein's theory also predicts
gravitational waves and black hole in
spirals and
math just seems to be more and more
useful and even all the successes of
artificial intelligence so far
suggests that the mathematical
descriptions of this
computation can actually at least kick
our butt in the chess and
translation soon and maybe driving cars
and so so why is that uh
i think the truth is we just don't know
and we should be humble and
acknowledge that but i i don't think
it's a fluke
james you you mentioned that our
standard model is actually
more complicated than it could be but to
put this in perspective
it's also a lot simpler than it could
have been right
true imagine if every single electron
were just different
you've discovered in your work that
every single electron you've ever looked
at
has exactly the same quantum numbers
they're
entirely equivalent particles like why
is that
i would i just i don't know
but i think i would pause it that if
there is a
somewhere in the multiverse maybe in the
level four multiverse or whatever
uh some other place where things are
incredibly complicated and every single
particle has its own separate properties
and everything is just completely messy
there would
probably be no versions of this program
happening right there because there
would be no point in even having your
brain there right there would be
if everything just looked completely
random you couldn't make any predictions
anyway so why have a brain
uh so maybe there are other regions
where
for some unfortunate where things are
messier and that's not where we are
or maybe there is some other deep reason
why
things are so him simple here uh i i try
to be just very humble and at least
admit i take very seriously the fact
that our universe was just way simpler
than it could have been
and i i think it's telling us something
so
sir max you um your book a mathematical
universe
which i believe i have right here uh for
sale at all good bookstores
uh you know you you posit that that in
in some sense
the the fundamental layer of reality is
mathematical that our universe is
fundamentally
mathematical and you know what we
perceive as physical emerges
from that uh i guess i have a couple of
questions firstly
do you still subscribe to this notion i
i totally do
i i should clarify what i subscribe to
also
because um there's a broad spectrum of
views as to what to make of this
apparent usefulness of math and science
right on one end of the spectrum you
have these people who say it means
nothing it's just the fluke
mouth is just something we invented
whatever get over it
and uh then there are a lot of people
who who feel
that math is uh for some reason very
very youthful but it's still just
an approximation an approximate
description of
of something which is fundamentally
non-mathematical i i
i'm in that book sticking my neck out
and taking the extreme opposite point of
view as far as you can go in the other
direction
and i i belong to a very small minority
of
scientists to think that but i think
it's interesting regardless of whether
you believe it or not
explore the range of possibilities and
now
what do i mean by that by saying that
our universe
is entirely mathematical i mean i mean
the hypothesis that
our physical world has no properties at
all
except mathematical properties and that
sounds just so dumb
when you first hear it like it just must
obviously be wrong just look behind me
here
at those trees there you know like what
what properties do they have
green kind of leafy
the leaves are a bit squishy and soft
that if you're
if you're a caterpillar maybe they're
yummy they don't sound
like mathematical properties right but
if we look at them
with your eyes as physicists here
what we actually see is a big there's a
bunch of quarks and electrons
back there and what are the properties
of an electron
well a minus one one half
one and so on and we have nerdy names
for them in physics of course james you
would call those the lepton number
the spin and the char electric charge
and so on but that's just the words that
we humans made up
right the electron doesn't care what we
call them the properties are
numbers and as james and stefan
will tell you the only difference is
that we know so far between an
up quark and an electron and a photon
are exactly those numbers that the
properties are
different numbers and what about the
space you see behind me here like what
property is this
that all that stuff is in what prop what
properties of space have well for
starters
the property three again
we have a math human name we made up for
it the dimensionality
of space the largest number of
perpendicular
fingers you can have in it right but
space doesn't care we call it it's a
number
and more we stephan talk spoke about
general relativity where we've also
discovered that space has the property
of
curvature which is just described by the
riemann tensor which is a hypercube of
four times four times four times four
numbers that's the mathematical thing
and also topology
which is a mathematical thing so if you
take seriously the idea that
so far the only properties we know for
sure that the stuff that makes
everything up
are mathematical and the only properties
of the space that it's in are also
mathematical
then it starts to sound a little bit
less insane i think that the idea that
maybe
it's actually all mathematical and we're
just part of this
mathematical object
said god made the integers the rest is
mentioned and so maybe sabine will say
that next week and she might even
critique
some of the things that we heard today
uh so that's just a teaser to tune in
she's in a well-known opponent of
such things ranging from the pursuit of
beauty leading
physicist astray in pursuing
mathematical beauty and elegance
i don't think i've heard matt correct me
if i'm wrong but i don't think i've
heard
any of these uh gentlemen these
physicists
using beauty for anything so i and i
often say and i said to sabine in my
interview with her on my podcast
and she'll be on next week so it's not
saying you know behind her back really
for more than seven days uh but you know
all experiments are beautiful and they
may not look beautiful but
i mean james maybe maybe we can we can
say a little bit more about this
uh this question before we start you
know turning to uh to some other topics
but uh stefan you want you're raising
your finger so
yeah i'll call it i'll say something
very quick in response to what max said
and what you
and also to address this issue of beauty
because i was exactly thinking about
sabine when when max was describing this
um because it is kind of the program if
you look at
all the approaches so far the quantum
gravity that i've played in
they all have some level of mathematical
elegance complexity
and they touch on different um branches
of mathematics some more
in the realm of algebraic topology some
in the level of symmetries
lee algebras and things like that right
so so i
resonate with what max is saying um
but i also want to talk about kind of
what james also mentioned which was
the notion that beauty kind of in this
is in the eyes of the beholder almost
like you know
what's beautiful to you you know there's
a saying every
every i think brian you've you he's have
the same every parent every ostrich
things there
their offspring is you know the best
it's the most beautiful thing
out there right um so this idea of
beauties also
seems to have a relativity to it so your
math
is more beautiful than somebody else's
math my theory is more beautiful
than your theory my colleagues at brown
the kind of
theories that they work on if you don't
work they'll be pissed off at me okay
but they love conformal field theory for
example right
um the math of zooming in and zooming
out and everything remaining the same
um so let me just say something about
that um
so it's more of a question
which is um so if it is the case that
you know there is some element of
that the universe really is is
mathematical
how do we bring into the how do we
account for the fact that
it's us humans that's discovering this
math and also
you know i don't want to say are we
inventing the math or are we
then discovering a math like and where
is that where is the sort of like
perspective of
you know this is more beautiful than the
other thing right because what's
complicated mathematics to me is simple
mathematics of somebody else
you know vice versa so that's what i
just thought
beauty as another you know rubric uh but
but i wonder
um uh if we can turn more towards you
know concrete examples there are people
in the chat that are asking these um
can we comment i mean do we want to dip
into this it's always dangerous to
criticize other people's ideas but but
and it takes a lot of bravery and
courage
uh to be a theorist to put ideas out
there
and uh you know some of the more kind of
controversial ones seem to be in the
zeitgeist
of the times right now with people such
as eric weinstein
as i already mentioned stephen wolfram
uh max
and uh and folks like garrett lisi uh
putting out
new theories what is it about this time
and what is it
about these theories that will allow us
to really make progress how do we get to
the bottom of it
given that a future collider is decades
off if it ever happens
uh and so by what standards will we be
judged in the future
maybe james you want to take that
yeah james might you start yeah sure i
mean
you know just a quick a couple of words
there so i mean in terms of
you know where we go from now i mean and
why this is such an interesting time for
uh really potentially game changing and
very
you know to use a kind of provocative
word wild theories of everything
that are coming out which i say with the
highest possible compliment um again it
kind of goes down it goes back to this
thing that i was
talking about the 20th century uh you
know history of particle physics and
just
physics in general in in the 20th
century is that it was this really kind
of like
clockwork uh uh you know progression of
sort of like strange observation uh cool
theoretical prediction
uh confirmation you know side prediction
confirmation and then this you know
it was this wonderful like almost like a
clockwork you know you have these
discoveries coming one after another
because they have these kind of like big
you know theoretical
uh hints these flashlights it's like you
should look over there because this is a
big theoretical hint and it's always
just you know been right where we're
waiting for it
um and we're out of those again and so
as and and it's almost as though the
20th century was so
successful in such a quick you know
quick 100 years way
that it got us to a realm of theoretical
understanding
that far outpaced our technological
capabilities as a civilization
under the assumption of the state you
know the
the standard uh you know theoretical and
also experimental and
technological uh language with which we
can't create experiments that can test
these ideas
and then that goes back to this idea of
the plunk scale right it's like once you
have quantum mechanics and gravity
and then we put these things you know uh
put these things together in the in the
in the you know dimensions of length and
time and energy
you suddenly get oh yeah there should be
something amazing happening this
gigantic energy that you probably can't
reach in our
civilization you know if at all you know
we it takes some other civilization to
be able to come up with this
uh energy and so that leads to this sort
of like again it's very strange in the
human brain when we
get this it's like ah but wait a minute
i want to be able to test this i want
something
you know where's the next discovery
coming from and there's no guarantees
anymore
so you know for me like i was saying as
an experimentalist i have to be very
sort of
you know like sober and also just like
straightforward it's like what do we
know
quantum field theory seems real uh and
we should go to as high possible
energies
as we can otherwise we'll never know
what's there just to be explore
right the other part of me says we need
new ideas and we need to you know
we need to foment more of these and so
in terms of the concrete ones that might
be
you know it's impossible to say which
one is is the best one and which one's
going to be
going to play out to be the you know the
the true nature of reality
but you know to me it kind of goes back
to the you know somebody mentioned
wheeler earlier
and i you know there's this diagram that
i think a lot of people have been
haunted by
you know ever since they saw it and i've
been hunted by this diagram that wheeler
came up with
um in one of his i forget which book but
it's the one where it's basically the
letter u
and on one side it's a very very thin uh
it's a very very thin
part of the u and the u turns around and
then it gets wider on the other side
and there's an eyeball on that part and
it's looking back at the
the initial part of the u so this is the
universe
that has at some point evolved someone
to then observe it
itself so you know we as humans are the
the method by which the universe
is asking questions and observing itself
and that to me
is again a sort of like very you know
profound statement about
compelling us to not just look at the
underpinnings of the con the
the current understanding of nature you
know quantum mechanics and general
relativity
but also think very critically about
what it means to be a a sentient
uh you know being in this universe and
asking questions about the universe
itself and that to me is you know i
think it'd be we could have an entire
show about you know the thing you
mentioned stefan
in fact i think it's a fascinating
question did humans did we invent
mathematics or did we actually discover
it i think we could have an entire discu
just you know discussion about that
question but i think at the end of the
day
you know these these how we're going to
make
further progress with you know is it
going to be like a wolfram style thing
which again wolfram's approach to such a
theory of everything as i think
you know if you want my personal opinion
i think it's fascinating it's really
really interesting it's also
really really really difficult to vet as
a scientific community
because it's just sort of like if it's
done in secret then it's dropped upon
the world it's like
i mean what do we do with this you can't
expect us just to suddenly go oh
yes we've changed everything and now
yours is the right one it's just that
you know it needs to it needs some kind
of
sort of embedding within the physics
community to really understand what's
going on
you know and in terms of things like
garrett lisey's ideas and these sort of
these sort of you know more speculative
ideas
again you know i i think i think we need
as many of these as possible and we need
to
do the you know we need to we need to
never really get
stuck in this notion of beauty um and
you know
because just you know one one last uh
point on this is that
in a sense this and you know there's
maybe there's some things with you know
for example you mentioned sabina maybe
sabine and i won't agree on everything
but there's certain things that i think
we definitely would be
would agree on is that you know this
notion of beauty
should not always just guide our
our our physics and especially
theoretical physics because
really at the end of the day what is
science you can argue where it came from
you can argue what you know how
consciousness arose you can argue
you know we can argue about what
intelligence is but science is really
if you think about it science is the
best method that we as humans have
that we invented to more or less reduce
to negligible the fact that we as humans
we love to
ascent to things because they're
beautiful when there's not actually a
pattern there when there's not actually
something real
we're very very good at ascending to
things just because it feels good
or it's emotionally interesting or you
know and that that is not
the way that you know but science is
like okay hold on
science recognizes that humans are
susceptible to this type of idea and
instead says okay
we need a coherent and like a very
robust set of rules
by which we can determine truth from
falsehood that reduces to negligible
this human
ability or this human tendency to ascend
to things due to beauty
so again you know this is not again like
max i i completely agree that the
the the leaves behind you are beautiful
but i also don't think that that
that that doesn't that doesn't indicate
that we can't
you know again reduce this this tendency
to negligible with science as
a pursuit so we need to uh ask
some uh audience questions max do you
have something quick to follow up well
it was important answer to the audience
question about the path forward
and then if i can also take 30 seconds i
can answer
what i think is the deal with whether
math is invented or
or discovered so if you
look if you think of jupiter we did not
invent jupiter we discovered jupiter
it's actually out there regardless of
whether we exist or not
but we invented the name jupiter we
could have called it shmupiter in
instead or in swedish we actually call
it
jupiter you know and it's exactly the
same way if you take for example
plato's five platonic solids
he discovered that there are five of
them the cube the tetrahedron and
octahedra and the dodecahedron
icosahedron
then he invented he invented the names
for them he could have called them the
shmodekahedron and the shmoop right
but he could never have invented a six
platonic solid
it just doesn't exist right the way
another planet in our solar system
doesn't
so that's that in terms of what you
commented on there the audience question
about the path forward
a piece of advice i would give is
look at each area of physics and ask
who's ahead
in that area experiment or theory if
you're taking
an area where there's the theory there's
a ton of theories
theory is far ahead of data dark energy
for example
we don't need another theory what we
really need there is
more measurements uh dark matter is the
same there's
almost as many dark matter theories as
there are theorists
we would really like to have more
measurements to try to rule out theories
and nail things down then there are
other areas where it's exactly the other
way around
uh take uh for example the the
particle data book and the many things
we can measure to 10 decimal places now
that we can only calculate the two
decimal places we'll loop
with lattice qcd right great area for
theorists to go into
uh and look at the those 32 numbers that
you mentioned earlier
so max we should we should take some
audience questions now because we're
nearly out of time
so and and you guys have been asking
like the really pragmatic stuff uh that
that you should be curious about so this
one this one's a great one
what all right we can't build a collider
the size of a galaxy
um so what maybe
i've seen star wars uh what may be what
is the speculated
accessible experimental data that could
reveal new frontiers in both quantum
physics and gravity
you know something like something
involving perhaps neutron stars or or
something like that
how can we get creative
uh anyone who has a thought on that i i
have my thoughts i think
looking at very high energy gamma-ray
bursts that
for example might give you the ability
to tell the difference between different
quantum gravity theories
because even though the effect is very
small when light flies a short distance
if it's been flying
for 10 billion years the effects can add
up
and in fact i think some quantum gravity
theories have been falsified
uh by exactly this sort of method yes
they have
uh different different wavelengths of
light seem to travel
at the same speed as each other uh high
energy ones are not slowed down
by the the little loop quantum gravity
uh facets that you might expect at those
scales so
you know things are testable to the
creator
i think uh dark matter substructure
experiments are made like me probe maybe
by
future gravitational lensing events um
there might be interesting predictions
um you know there are some
crazy ideas on the table that people
with with
models of dark matter again that i i
don't
i don't claim to subscribe to them or
not but you know the idea is like
theories of dark matter that have some
quantum gravity ideas in it
that may predict substructure maybe
think in future about
substructure i think also the simon's
telescope looking at um
certain um effects of birefringence
might be another thing quantum theories
of gravity seem to go there as well
if i can just take two quick things sort
of my very you know
very brief opinion on what the you know
where we need to go next is that
again like i was saying before we need
to do all types of experiments
simultaneously because who knows where
the the deviation from expectation is
going to show up
but i really think that multi-messenger
astronomy so this is you know
looking for uh you know looking for like
cosmic ray cosmic rays gamma
gamma reverse you know uh uh but also
gravitational wave astronomy these kinds
of things
this of course will be pursued in
earnest and it has to be
but simultaneously the next generation
of colliders
either higher energy ones or the kind of
more ones where would produce a very
very large number of higgs boson
particles
um those are going to be just more or
less game changers i mean there's really
no question whether we should have large
experiments that can create
a large number of higgs bosons because
the higgs boson is sort of like
we you know we have this gigantic
standard model which is awesome
and we understand everything really
really well like pinpoints but our
understanding of the higgs boson is like
gigantic and it could be this fantastic
portal into
possibly answers to some of these
questions so you know is it the only
fundamental scalar field that exists in
the universe
or are there other ones that are related
to it is it in fact composite is there
structure inside there
is it in fact does it actually talk to
dark matter and also
does it have what's the shape of its
potential and that
if you measure the shape of the
potential of the higgs boson very very
precisely which is what's planned for
future experiments
that'll give you a window into how the
universe in fact
came about exactly the way it did right
around the moment of the big bang you
know was it a first order phase
transition for like
electro weak symmetry breaking or was it
something else and also
what the fate of the universe is so
these kind of things together
they sort of have to be done otherwise
we'll just be ignorant for you know for
decades
we need a shout out to inflation also
it's brian's wheelhouse here because
obviously to learn about quantum gravity
we would like to look at physics where
it's both
very small and very massive so either
end states a black hole evaporation
or are big bang and uh
it's a real bummer that you lost in
nobel prize brian how could you
because if you had discovered
gravitational waves and you had kept
them around right
or maybe in the future if you do it with
a just at a lower amplitude
then uh that might very well give us
fantastic clues about quantum gravity oh
that might be my next book winning that
maybe just seguing to that maybe
stephanie can pick up this last question
yeah i want to actually resonate with
what game said i think like my my
post soccer advisor michael peskin
convinced me of this that
we simply don't know what electro weak
symmetry breaking is that's what
james is referring to the current
standard model that's a placeholder
and it could be actually the higgs is
also the higgs and discovering
its true nature which will tell us about
electric wheat symmetry break-in
might actually have clues to quantum
gravity we just don't know
so i think i want to resonate what james
said about
particle collide or physics as well yeah
so last question i had maybe it ties
into a little bit of what max was saying
maybe not uh
we hear a lot about the anthropic
principle and maybe tie-ins between
inflation the multiverse
the landscape swampland all these things
are those potential guiding
uh you know fruitful guiding avenues to
understand the theory of everything or
those likely to be
a wild gooth chase i thought that was
funny
i think the the one thing i hate about
the anthropic principle
is that the word principle is in there
as if it's somehow
optional when it's in fact just
the correct use of use of statistics
that shouldn't be optional
you know if you if you have a write a
paper saying you you studied
the size distribution of fishes in a
pond then your net is this wide and you
didn't find any fish is smaller than
that that paper just should get rejected
that's not a principle i i think
fundamentally physics is about making
predictions for what observers should
observe and making experiments to see if
those predictions are borne out or not
then
you just have to do the calculations
correctly and
if it happens that in that you make a
big space and
some properties are different in
different parts and some don't have
observers you just have to fold that
into your mouth otherwise
your whole predict your whole analysis
is rubbish
so we only have a few minutes left and
and i wanted to
you know maybe end by where we should
have started you know physics is great
at really defining its problems and
we're quite precise
um you know because we have math uh but
you know i do wonder sometimes if we're
even asking the right question or if we
know what question we're asking so when
we
try to search for a theory of everything
what are we doing are we asking what is
the primal cause why is there something
rather than nothing
or are we being more pragmatic are we
trying to find the equation
that fits on the hat so that we can do
all the calculations with one equation
uh i would love to just each of you to
maybe say what
what do you think the final answer
will feel like um maybe you step on if
you'd like
well i'm gonna speculate i think that um
the final answer should bring into
account
um the human being um and
the diversity of the of the human being
the different perspectives
i mean i have friends who um who i'm
also musician so you know i was just i'm
a big fan of
classical indian music i have friends
who you know
their approach to playing like music is
has a mathematical linguistic take
um as a jazz musician for example the
role of improvisation
as a scientific way into creating music
that ends up like john coltrane looking
very mathematical
and what's that about right what's the
informational content of that so i think
like the various ways of bringing in the
very observers max i resonate with max
big time in this
how to do that i mean general relativity
gave us hints about how to do that
i want to give a plug to my friend eric
weinstein he has this idea of the
observable
verse and his theory i so i think we
should have a marketplace of ideas but i
definitely the end game
i think will will start with us as
humans the ones doing the creation
and not throwing a baby out with the
bathwater we have theories that work and
they
predict things but you know and i think
moving forward how do we
bring all these different perspectives
into that new what that new science
looks like
how to how to engage each other as human
beings and doing that
beautiful max
yeah at the risk of uh sounding like
stefan and i have a mutual admiration
society going here
i i will agree entirely with with the
idea that
we need to talk seriously about what an
observer is
uh i would suggest we don't just talk
about human observers there was a very
cute
chipmunk that just walked under the
table here a minute ago i'm quite sure
it's observing
too i think in the future we might see
uh
digital minds that we've built ourselves
that can also observe
i i suspect that we'll be able to find
an end game where you have some
mathematical equations or some
computation that describes
what we call our universe and by
studying it you can not only realize
that it's going to have these observers
in it but you can calculate what they're
going to observe
and if it agrees with what james and
other experimentalists actually find
then you can start to think hey maybe
this is it
maybe this is what we should put on on
the brian keating's future
baseball cap march speaking of merch
uh matt uh maybe have a few uh final
words and we'll wrap up with a little
teaser for
i i would like to hear james take oh
yeah sorry yeah james
please just ten seconds with my opinion
on that i think that the final answer
you know if you're asking that question
i'm not convinced there is going to be a
final answer and i'm not saying that
from sort of like a hippie-ish
perspective i'm saying that the history
of science has been such that it's a
human pursuit of constructing knowledge
and constructing our understanding of
the
universe in a better way and a little
bit more advanced as we go along
even if we were to you know to discover
that at its basis univ you know the
nature of the fundamental nature of
reality is somehow mathematical and
informational which are
kind of the same thing um then we would
you know and if we were able to figure
out a way to communicate with a part of
the
observable universe or the universe that
we're not within or some other universe
even if we were come up with that that
would open up new realms that we would
then need to explain
and i think this is why i'm not
convinced there's a final theory
other than humans as one version of a
conscious being a sentient being in the
universe that have come up with this way
to ask questions about the place in
which we happen to be and i think that i
totally agree i'd love to see what the
squirrel's version of science is i would
love to see what a different you know
civilizations version of science is i'm
not convinced there's a final answer but
i
absolutely loving the fact that we as
humans get to ask these questions
that's life 4.0 and max's lexicon one
for each level of the multiverse matt
you want to take it away
yeah speaking of books so um before we
wrap up there are
some winners of uh some of these amazing
books i'm gonna
uh read those out now so the winner of
max tegmarx our mathematical universe is
chris lidyard
congrats chris um the winner of brian's
losing the nobel prize
marion edwards the winner of stephen
alexander's jazz of physics is omar
subbasi
and the there are space-time t-shirts
for
we have aiden beckley um
my i can't quite read that
uh is this tino uh patricia
katrina petrina um i apologize um and
arbonne nuriana so
congratulations those well you'll need
to um
email us at pbsspacetime gmail.com
uh and we'll get those out to you
um so brian any comments for not having
my book done otherwise somebody could
win my book but it's not done yet sorry
but you have finished it it's just not
in this particular universe
well i want to uh thank everybody and
just remind
everybody out there why we're doing this
because as james and max and stefan have
highlighted so spectacularly it's really
amazing it's almost a miracle
if you think about it how how what a
time we live in
and how exciting it is that we human
brains can actually
access some of the deeper regions of the
universe and perhaps
unravel future mysteries for our you
know great great great
grandchildren advisees to uh to take on
in their phd theses
it's a very vibrant field and i want to
advertise next week's show we're going
to have lisa randall
again she was supposed to be on today
she'll be on next week uh the
effervescent sabine hassenfelder eric
weinstein
and all of us have a soft spot in our
heart for lee smallin
he will be on next week as well and uh
we invite the guests to join in
next week uh you the three of you
gentlemen and please join in the chat in
case we
bring something up maybe we'll read that
out and uh
sign up for the to get notifications
about that next week
and you'll receive an entry into winning
the books by
uh sabine lisa and uh eric and lee
so these are not eric eric doesn't have
a book either we're going to work on
that
but for now matt any anything else you
want to say i just had
such a blast with you guys despite you
know two of the three of you being
theorists
uh it was great now i'm just kidding
love you guys all thank you so much for
taking us up on this and and the
audience out there phenomenal questions
stay engaged we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can
in the next 13.8 billion years and
brian thank you for uh helping pull this
together
um you guys have to check out uh brian's
podcast into the impossible
um it yeah you're you'll there's some
incredible incredible conversations um
stefan i watched through all of your
conversations with uh
with brian i learned an awful lot uh so
really
just thank you all i you know did we
figure out the answer well i think what
we figured out
is that the brightest minds of our time
are
um really struggling with at this point
the most
fundamental philosophical as well as uh
scientific questions uh and if you like
can't figure it out well
then i guess we'll never understand
space talks
no no no that's why we need all the
young listeners
or watching this to come study physics
yeah and help us answer it and watch
great resources on pbs space time studio
physics is not some sort of stale old
field like
calculus which is all done you just go
learn this is work in progress
that's true we should mention that
matt's the videos that matt has on pbs
space time those are a really good intro
to
anybody that's out there it's like maybe
i should actually think about majoring
in physics
yeah you should do that next week
actually there's loop quantum gravity
there's theories of everything
and many other resources thanks to matt
and his awesome team i just look up to
you guys so much
thanks everybody i can't wait to see
what we come up with next yes
thank you guys